I'll just tell you we've been to the
bottom the oceans we've been to ancient
Greek mythology we've been to the past
in the future flash into the digital
world with cyborg we still got to go to
space so the Green Lantern's and the
Green Lantern Corps will be coming to
join the Justice of the universe hey
everybody it's Charlie huge news DC just
announced what's going on
going forward post Justice League so
obviously we have Green Lantern Corps
Geoff Johns is gonna be writing and
producing that himself because he
recently just quit his job as chief
creative officer and took up a job more
like Greg Berlanti developing TV shows
and movies for Warner Brothers so I know
this is huge news like you probably read
all the news releases like saying that
he's stepping down from his position
basically what's going on is that he's
like a new Greg Berlanti person he gets
to write he gets to do DC movies now so
he gets a huge pay increase and they
just announced what all the big projects
he's gonna be working on first art so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the DC videos
there's a new route of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video but the big deal is
they just started shooting Wonder Woman
- there's like this retro looking
parking lot we're calling it Wonder
Woman 84 because that's the teaser that
they released like Wonder Woman
84 or what's going on with that like we
know that sheet is gonna be and we know
it's gonna be set during 1984 but we'll
continue to see stuff from behind the
scenes so we'll get an idea for what's
actually going on so right now they're
just shooting scenes in Washington DC
set during 1984 but what's happened
behind the scenes at DC entertainment
since they'll the Justice League fallout
happened is that basically the
executives have either been shuffled
into other positions they've been fired
or they've resigned so like just a
little while ago the former president
Diane Nelson resigned like I'm gonna go
seek other challenges that's code for
fallout from all the movies that didn't
pan out the way that they wanted them to
so it's like okay we're gonna put new
executives in power try a new slate of
films Geoff Johns is just gonna get to
be the person to actually create the
Green Lantern Corps movie it'll be like
his baby now which i think makes sense
like we all probably wondered why geoff
johns wasn't doing more of this himself
anyway but in addition
to the Green Lantern Corps movie he gets
his own sub imprint the way that Bendis
does on a lot of big comic book labels
like Marvel created a special label for
him to keep him exclusive at Marvel but
he just came to DC so Geoff Johns gets a
version of that too the extras name for
it is pretty hardcore it's called the
killing zone the name of his production
company that's gonna be producing all
these DC TV shows and movies is called
Mad Ghost which actually sounds pretty
cool the TV shows that he's developing
you've already heard about I've already
been doing videos about those so Titans
he created and he's personally riding on
he also created Doom Patrol like I've
already explained how the Doom Patrol is
gonna debut on Titans and they're gonna
spin off to their own show they'll start
shooting Doom Patrol this summer
it'll be 13 episodes just like Titans
but it probably won't premiere till next
year depending on how fast things move
along the quote that he released
actually just reads I took a role at DC
entertainment because I love the
characters and I love the universe more
than anything but I want to spend my
days writing and on set I'm thrilled to
get back in a more hands-on creative
role it's a dream job with dream
projects reaching even deeper into DC's
vast pantheon of characters so it sounds
like what the situation was when he was
still chief creative officer is that he
just had an oversight role and they
didn't let him write or work on any of
the movies in a really big way some of
the articles that have been talking
about this also say that he clashed very
loudly with DC management about the
film's particularly Diane Nelson so I
don't know what kind of drama there was
behind the scenes when they were making
all these movies for the last like five
or six years but whatever it was it
sounds like Geoff Johns wasn't allowed
to actually do any real work now there
was the Batman script that he wrote with
Ben Affleck a long time ago remember
where Deathstroke was gonna be the main
villain that's when they brought Joe
Manganiello
on and I think it was gonna be a bigger
thing I think it's common knowledge now
that part of the deal that Matt Reeves
got when they hired him was that he got
to do his own script so like whatever it
was that Geoff Johns and Ben Affleck did
with that Deathstroke character like
that movie is just on a shelf somewhere
now maybe they'll make it down the road
but we know that they're making a
Deathstroke movie with Gareth Evans
that's actually been delayed so if
you've been looking forward to that
you're gonna have to wait for a while
long
but Joe Manganiello is still attached so
it's still gonna happen you just gonna
have to wait a little while longer to
see it but it sounds like Green Lantern
Corps is gonna get fast-tracked a little
bit now so for all of you've been
waiting to see a really badass Green
Lantern movie now is our opportunity but
they're saying that he's just writing
and producing it so that means that he's
not gonna direct but because it's his
baby he'll probably get to pick who the
director is himself so I wouldn't expect
to hear too much about that this year
usually I mean it takes about a solid
year to get a really good script for a
movie out originally I think it was
gonna be 2020 when they were planning on
releasing it it was still gonna be like
way down the road they wanted to put
some distance between Ryan Reynolds
Green Lantern I'm sure Ryan Reynolds
wants that too but as far as we know
it's still going to be the Lethal Weapon
type story with an older Hal Jordan in a
younger Jon Stewart
they just haven't cast any of the
characters yet but I'm sure they're like
every actor in Hollywood is up for it
now we both know why I was
transferred everybody thinks I'm
suicidal in which case I'm and
nobody wants to work with me or they
think I'm faking to draw psycho pension
in which case I'm and nobody
wants to work with me basically I'm
guess what what really cool
inside baseball detail Geoff Johns got
his start in Hollywood working for
Richard Donner who was the person who
did the Lethal Weapon series but if you
saw that video of Geoff Johns with Kevin
Feige because for a little while we were
hoping that Geoff Johns would become the
Kevin Feige of DC Kevin Feige got his
start in Hollywood around the same time
as Geoff Johns also working for Richard
Donner you remember this the first time
I ever went to comic-con you you and I
were in the office
it was slow time I had been hired by
Marvel but hadn't officially left to go
work there yet and it was like three
o'clock in the afternoon on a Thursday
or something and we got into his Jeep
and drove down to San Diego and then you
stayed because you knew some common
people there and I drove the car back oh
yeah that was awesome I love it yeah it
was great yeah what you've done is
insane and I loved watching it because
it's it's so phenomenal and I love it
all but I love it because I remember
when you built that shed on top of your
apartment building I didn't know that
was legal but yeah I think I didn't ask
for a permit
what did I put in that Star Trek
figures toys yes which is the funny
situation where you have two of the most
powerful comic-book producers in
Hollywood getting their start under the
same shingle so when we talk about
Lethal Weapon Green Lantern it's just
like bring it full circle for Jeff Jones
if they wind up keeping that motif the
funny thing about this - if you were a
big fan of Jeff Jones rebirth and you
really like what he's doing with
Doomsday Clock they're saying that his
executive position at DC entertainment
while he was chief creative officer kept
him from writing more comic books the
first big comic book projects that he's
working on are gonna be a Shazam story
which I don't think it's gonna have
anything to do with the Shazam movie
it'll just be a Shazam story and then
the story about the three Joker's that
he teased back during rebirth if you
wonder what happened with that because
they tease that there are actually three
different Joker's that exist in the DC
Universe it sounds like he was just too
busy with his executive duties
day-to-day to actually work on that so
now he'll just have the opportunity to
do that he also helped co-create the
flash TV show I would be down for him to
take over that but technically that's
Greg Berlanti show so I think that's why
you're seeing a little bit of separation
between the DC streaming service shows
the Jeff Jones is developing in all the
CW DC TV shows but because he is like a
king of really big crossovers I wouldn't
throw out the idea of any kind of
crossover happening down in the future I
think it just depends on how things go
with them launching this DC streaming
service and now that he's taken this new
role they've announced everything it's
probably been in the works for a while
he's probably been waiting til Comic Con
to make like a lot of really big
announcements about what's going on
drop footage for everything particularly
Titans I've already done a video about
that because we found out when they're
actually launching all that stuff so
I'll link that video at the end of this
so just leave all your video requests in
the comments below we'll find out more
about Aquaman at Comic Con too I think
because we haven't seen footage yet
they're just really waiting for Comic
Con I'll be doing videos for the Sony
stuff at e3 later tonight like
spider-man ps4 Last of Us to that stuff
that'll happen later tonight so while
you wait for that click here to learn
about when that
see streaming service and Titans is
launching and then click here for other
brand-new Avengers thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight